every conference I've ever been to right
around this time they all say I know
we're all tired we're only a couple more
sessions so so I won't say that we know
we're all tired now we're going to talk
about government yes yes right are you
ready for government no so for most of
us a trip to the DMV or to the
permitting Department or the county
clerk is a maybe infuriating experience
may be a boring experience may be a
frustrating experience but for Jennifer
pahlka it's in some sense an inspiring
experience Jennifer created Code for
America which is a kind of geek Peace
Corps for geeks which places coders and
web types in local governments to help
it work better so that's what we're
going to talk about so tell me the
status of Code for America you you give
out fellowships every year how many how
many fellows how many fellows have there
been and how many governments what are
we talking about here here thanks for
having me this is really fun I
appreciate all of you for sticking
around and not leaving the room when
government comes up so this is our
second ear we've got 26 fellows this
year they're assigned to eight cities so
basically they're in teams of three or
four last year we were all work with
only three cities we have 19 fellow so
it's a little bit different mix this
year so the mix of fellows is sort of
designed to replicate you know the
average startup team so you have a
developer to designer maybe somebody
with product management skills and the
notion is that they're working like a
start-up team and in fact love to follow
eric ries because we have them read the
Lean Startup the first day they get in
we follow his methodology they're
working like a little startup inside of
bureaucracy and so we have these deep
connections with the cities around in
identifying a problem space where they
want to try this new methodology and
having that that team come in and what
sorts of projects are people working on
cumin and some examples of what's been
done um so this year we're working with
eight city
in Detroit in New Orleans both they're
working on a problem you'd probably
guess if you wondered if you know we
were doing it on your own it's a working
on blighted property so you know for
example city has a certain set of data
around the different blighted properties
and the neighborhood the neighbors have
a different set of data they know really
you know that so and so's brother is
coming to take over this home that seems
to be a blighted property the city tends
to demolish that house the one that's
about to be about to be renovated
instead of the several others that
really should be and so we're working on
fixing a problem like that in Santa Cruz
our team is working on streamlining the
business permitting process much like
going the DMV many of you entrepreneurs
in the audience that had the experience
trying to file all the paperwork that
you need to file and it's not a lot of
fun and it's very confusing so they're
creating a much better interface for
that process I'll give you a good
example of one of the concrete project
that our fellows did last year in Boston
so they were working a number of
different issues primarily in the public
schools last year in Boston and in the
middle of the year there was an article
written in the Boston Globe about how
frustrated parents were because they've
changed the system of how you could
figure out which schools your kid could
was eligible to go to and the way that
parents were supposed to figure this out
was to read a very dense 28 page printed
brochure that had a little paragraph and
you know seven point font about each of
the schools but you could read this
entire thing and still not know which
school your kid could go to and so this
became a problem for the mayor because
it was it was being publicized very
heavily how frustrating it was and they
asked our fellows to take a crack at it
they did a really beautiful website
that's called discover bps you can see
it discover bps org it's pretty basic
you type in the address where you live
the age of your child and whether you
have any siblings in a public school and
it returns a mapped list of the schools
that you're eligible for and then you
can compare and take notes and sort of
do little things that modern web app
will do and it
not that this is such rocket science
it's that our fellows started coding in
August there was one guy on it full time
two guys working on at part time and
they pushed it live to the web in
October and we were told if it had gone
through normal channels in government it
would have taken at least two years and
cost at least two million dollars and
this is a real problem for government
the cost is unacceptable we shouldn't
with the budgets in municipal government
right now massive crisis we should not
be spending orders of magnitude more
then we should be on on technology like
this the timing is really an issue too
because we have this lack of trust in
government and how can you trust
government if they can't fix a problem
in less than two years but the other
thing that was interesting about it for
me is just the way that the app looked
and feel and the way that it felt in the
way that it worked we're so used to
these really cluttered confusing
interfaces to government particularly on
the web where you look at and you just
can't figure out what you're supposed to
do it's laden with a bunch of difficult
confusing language and we had the
fellows come in the very first year we
SAT them down and asked them why are you
here you know what is it that is driving
you to take a year off they work for a
very small stipend they could be making
much more doing something else they work
incredibly hard in very difficult
circumstances and it's a big sacrifice
so you know we ask these guys what are
you doing here and one of them looked at
me and said this guy Scott so firmly
said I'm here because I believe that
interfaces to government could be simple
beautiful and easy to use and when they
pushed bps discover VPS org live to the
web I looked at this and I said that's a
simple beautiful easy-to-use interface
to government and we as citizens have to
expect that of government we lost the
ability to even want that out of
government because we haven't seen it
and that's an important part of what
we're trying to do right and when you
think about you know an organization
that's 180 degrees from the Silicon
Valley system of you know launching not
being afraid to fail iterating yeah you
know local gov
it seems the absolute opposite of that
you know that it's it's supposed to be
ossified and everybody's very risk
averse and worried about their own
positions and how do you find a foothold
in these in these types of organizations
which run in very different ways how
does how do how do the how does the
logic of a web company work its way into
local government well I think the
surprising thing that i found i mean i
started this about two years ago on with
some vague notions of what might work
and a real sort of shocked about how
government worked and but i didn't
realize is there's actually an enormous
number of very innovative creative
people in government I wouldn't call
them the majority but there's enough of
them and I think that's the important
part so the way we run the program it's
a competitive process on both sides so
the fellows compete to be part of it we
had 550 people apply for just 26 slots
so we're getting fantastic people and we
do the same thing with the cities we
make them compete so this year we've had
32 cities apply for a next year program
will probably choose eight again but
they the cities have to demonstrate that
they can work with us they have to have
some evidence of innovation going on
already some willingness to take risks
some understanding of what it's going to
be like to work with a lean startup
group inside of governments at a
bureaucracy and that they're willing to
take some of the you know the politico
into be political hits there's going to
be resistance we know that going in and
so we need good partners I am very happy
to report that there are a lot of good
partners and local government we have
many more cities we'd like to work with
that we can't but there it's it I think
when people think about bureaucrats
there's a certain image that comes to
mind and I'm not saying that you know
your hundred percent wrong about that
but I do see that there's also something
called a public servant and there's many
many more of these and these are people
that are certainly hamstrung very very
difficult system that's that's holding
them back but they went into it because
they actually want to serve the public
and if we can tap that great energy and
that instinct and that desire to do well
and bring it into a different context I
think there's really something to
work with their so you come in you
launch a new app or a new interface or
what have you you're there for one year
and then you're gone yeah and what
happens then well we're supposed to be
there for a year and leave we ended up
doing Philadelphia two years in a row
because we loved working with them and
they made a good case for it but then
the notion is that we should only be
there for a year because we can't become
their innovation ghetto right we have to
you know we're showing what's possible
and then we're trying to push the push
the the will to change back on them
we're gonna leave you guys need to
figure out what you learned from working
with us for a year we need to learn what
we you know we figure out what we've
learned from working with them and our
fellows need to learn that too but then
you guys need to institutionalize the
changes that came from seeing what's
really possible with technology and so
we try to work with a completely
different set of cities every year lots
of different things happen I mean we see
a number of changes in these cities we
see new job titles where they get at you
know they have actually hiring Civic
hackers within government which is
fantastic we see people who had formerly
been really marginalised like people who
had data and we're advocating for open
data platforms who had been you know
kind of you know pushed to the side
after year of Code for America those
guys are getting promoted and now
they're leading we see all these great
sort of structural cultural changes
within city government which is
fantastic and we have to work with them
on sustainability of the applications so
you know one of the things we're seeing
which is gray is that the apps that
these guys build our open source and we
had an example last year our adopt a
hydrant program is actually now looks
like it may end up in like nine cities
they're just people are finding it on
our github account and re implementing
it so that's one great way that we can
we see these things being sustained but
we're also now looking at how can some
of these applications become businesses
so we've just launched this code for
america accelerator which is you know
basically a Y Combinator an accelerator
but particularly for civic startups
he'll work with governments so some of
these things will live on in government
some of them
become businesses wow so alright so
let's say I'm a recent Stanford grad and
I've got a number of options before me I
can take a job at Google I can join y
combinator or go the startup route
what's your pitch to me why should i
take this year and spend it in a city
hall somewhere ok well I'll pitch you
simultaneously on doing our fellowship
or doing our accelerator ok great really
either one but yeah I think that's the
thing most Stanford grads come out
they're told by the entrepreneurial
community like solve a problem in your
own life well maybe there aren't that
many problems in your life if you're a
recent Stanford grad you've got a lot of
opportunity in front of you we've built
this amazing internet that does that you
know this consumer internet that does so
much it makes our lives so connected and
so convenient you are eventually going
to hit up against government in your
life and it will be a problem you will
have and so my name my main pitch is is
just that that this is going to be
something that you'll encounter at some
point in your life I think the thing
though to understand is that we you know
it's a hundred and seventy two billion
dollar market government technology
that's far bigger than it needs to be
it's right for disruption we talk about
disruptive by design this is an enormous
market opportunity there is so much that
could be done so much low-hanging fruit
that could be picked in all sorts of
areas and there's just new models that
haven't been applied so it's the last
big undisrupted market that needs
tackling it's going to affect you in
your life one way or the other but you
know when it comes right down to it
government we can't give up on
government we can pretend that it isn't
going to bother as we contend pretend to
work around it but only for so long our
public institutions are crumbling
they're failing because we are not
bringing that same spirit of innovation
that we're bringing to the media world
into robotics and to all the wonderful
things you've heard about the day we
need to be bringing that to government
if we're really going to have a society
that works so the Tim O'Reilly famous
for the sprays which has now been you
know credited to basically everybody
every politician who's running
no but I think it's really his
government at its core is what we do
together it's that simple and when we do
need it to work we just need it to work
a lot better you know it's very easy to
get as you say sort of dejected and just
decide to shut off you've talked a
little bit about the distinction between
politics mm-hmm and government can you
can you explore that a little bit
further for us yeah I mean I think we're
at this moment where there's this huge
frustration with politics and the
political process so we have lowest
rates of voting especially at local
elections where you may you look at your
this ballot and you're like I don't even
know who I'm voting for I don't know
what these offices mean I don't know
what these candidates stand for and you
have very low rates of participation so
a lot of people are trying to solve that
problem but to me we're not going to
solve the political problem until we
actually acknowledge that the political
layer is this very thin layer on top of
a vast system underneath that we call
bureaucracy and the reason that we're
all sitting here going ok I worked
really hard to get this new person
elected into office and nothing changed
you know it feels like eventually like
you're hitting your head against the
wall it's not changing because we're
only looking at that tiny shallow input
device at the big at the top the this
politics if we don't actually fixed the
operating system underneath the politics
the huge bureaucracy it's not going to
matter who we elect and this is starting
to become a much more popular notion um
David Brooks has been writing about Tom
Friedman said this in his last column
last Sunday and the times you know it's
not going to matter who we elect we've
got to really have to look at it like a
giant blow to I mean with you know I'm
not a software programmer so hopefully
this is an accurate metaphor but it's
like a giant bloated operating system
you change the font on the home screen
it doesn't optimize the system right
until we start getting beurette
bureaucratically active our political
activity is not he's going to mean less
and less well Jennifer you've done
amazing work over the last couple of
years and in honor of that I'd like to
call out of miles Nadal who has a
presentation well thank you yeah thank
you thank you Jennifer it's really an
honor and a privilege to meet you you
know when we when we think about
entrepreneurship and challenging
conventional wisdom being an insurgent
challenging status quo we never think
about government in the same way and as
you describe what is a hundred and
seventy two billion dollar industry and
your description that said we need to
make sorry that quote was we made to
make changes in government together we
created the MDC humanitarian award to
recognize extraordinary people who are
using entrepreneurship creativity
innovation and disruption to make a
difference in the lives of other people
on a humanitarian basis and we can't
think of a more deserving person or
organization than yourself and Code for
America as more deserving recipients so
on behalf of all of us here all of my
partners and colleagues at MDC partners
are our colleagues had wired we're going
to present you with this award and
twenty thousand dollars as a small
investment in your extraordinary
initiatives and hopefully we can see
ourselves getting more involved in what
you're doing because i think the things
that you are doing will have benefit for
many years to come there was a great
quote by forest rich witchcraft that i
use all the time that said a hundred
years from now no one will ever remember
the car you drove the house you lived in
it for that matter how much money you
had in your bank account but the world
maybe be a different place if you made a
difference in the life of a young person
there's no question in our minds that
what you are doing and what Code for
America is doing will have generational
impact at a very positive way on a
humanitarian basis so please keep up the
amazing work you should be very proud
and we're on
privilege to give you this award thank
you
I just want to thank you so much miles
and everybody at MDC and to wired and to
Chris and Thomas who saw me and a couple
months ago I think you know we're really
new organization and this award and and
the the grant means so much to us and
then I really appreciate and I just
appreciate the opportunity that for us
to be aligned with this notion of
disruptive by design and thank you so
much for your support our pleasure